este es un simulador que se encuentra en
can academy que fue desarrollado por la
usuaria charlotte
avn y que nos permite obtener muestras
de la máquina de dulces para aproximar
la distribución muestral de proporciones
esta simulación se refiere a dulces
verdes pero en el vídeo anterior
hablamos de dulces amarillos y dijimos
que el 60% de los dulces son amarillos
así que pongamos aquí 60% de dulces
verdes las muestras serán de 10 dulces
en cada ocasión y comencemos con una
muestra queremos ver los porcentajes de
cada muestra que son de dulces verdes en
esta primera muestra 5 dulces de 10
salieron verdes y se ubican aquí en esta
gráfica es una muestra del 50% tomamos
otra muestra y ahora salieron 7 dulces
verdes es una muestra del 70% tomamos
otra muestra y ahora salieron tres
dulces verdes así que es una muestra del
30% sigamos haciendo esto y aumentemos
el número de muestras que obtenemos en
el simulador de manera que tengamos un
número muy grande de muestras aquí ya
tenemos más de 1.000 muestras
interesante aquí es que vemos
experimentalmente que la proporción
media muestral es 0.61 y lo que
calculamos hace unos momentos es que
debía ser 0.6 también vimos que la
desviación estándar de la proporción
muestral es 0.16 y lo que calculamos era
aproximadamente igual a 0.15 así que
mientras más muestras obtengamos nos
acercaremos cada vez más a los valores
exactos que calculamos como podemos ver
ahora en el simulador entre más muestras
tomamos más nos acercamos a los valores
que habíamos calculado antes algo
interesante que vemos aquí es que cuando
la proporción de la población no está
cercana a 0 ni está cercana a 1 esto se
parece mucho a una distribución normal
esto tiene sentido porque existe una
relación entre la distribución muestral
de proporciones y una variable aleatoria
binomial pero qué pasa si la proporción
de la población es cercana a 0 digamos
que es 10% 0.1
como se verá la distribución en este
caso sabemos que la media de la
distribución muestral
10% por lo que podemos imaginar que la
distribución será asimétrica a la
derecha vamos a verlo en efecto vemos
que la distribución es asimétrica a la
derecha esto tiene sentido porque solo
podemos tener valores entre 0 y 1 y si
la media se encuentra cercana a 0
veremos la parte más alta de la
distribución aquí y tendrá una cola
larga a la derecha que ocasiona la
asimetría si ahora la proporción de la
población es cercana a 1 veremos que
sucede lo contrario tendremos una
asimetría a la izquierda como lo podemos
ver aquí en la simulación otra cosa
interesante aquí es que mientras más
grande sea el tamaño de las muestras más
pequeña será la desviación estándar
ponemos la proporción de la población
justo en medio y vemos que está como al
principio
la distribución luce más o menos normal
cuando tenemos el tamaño de la muestra
igual a 10 pero qué pasa si ahora el
tamaño de la muestra es igual a 50 vean
que ahora luce una distribución más
compacta vean que ni siquiera llega a 1
la razón por la que esto tiene sentido
es porque la desviación estándar de la
proporción muestral es inversamente
proporcional a la raíz cuadrada de n
espero que con esto tengan una mejor
comprensión acerca de la proporción
muestral la distribución muestral de
proporciones de la que podemos calcular
su media y su desviación estándar además
pudimos verificar todo esto en un
simulador nos vemos en otro vídeo